foreign
[Music]
classic
welcome back to the corridor digital
podcast episode 175.
we're glad you're here everybody I've
got some very special people with us
today we've got Griffin Thorne the
mystery man himself who keeps getting
more tattoos which one will we get next
yeah a knife Jordan Allen yeah
this guy this guy dude and of course the
lovely Jordan Coleman everybody
hello Don't Clap for that
food is already strong it's already
going strong
all right so Griffin but for real though
I've noticed you've been getting more
and more tattoos yeah yeah where's your
what's where's this coming from
um I I got my first tattoo in 2019 and I
definitely caught the bug and um you're
in the bug phase right now I'm in the
bug phase I'm yeah just trying to strike
the balance between um getting getting
the body suit you know probably maybe
before M40 but also not just filling my
body up with with you know stuff for the
sake of doing it wow bodysuit means down
to ankles up to neck yeah probably I'll
probably stop at the neck or like do you
I'm actually I'm so sorry I'm just
genuinely curious in a bodysuit do you
spend money on the cheeks the butt
cheeks yeah yeah it would look weird if
you didn't oh yeah oh my gosh that's
crazy because they're so expensive like
white butt cheeks and then a
bunches Griffin you know what you should
do you should do a fake fake whitey
tighty lines around your butt and hit
and waist oh that's a good idea that's
genius what is that sunblock you know
the the little girl yeah yeah
I probably will skip I probably will
skip the neck
I'll definitely skip this stomach for at
least as long as I can because that's
that's horrendous but like I'm actually
um
quite afraid of needles okay and I don't
know if I can do anything like on like
the the jugular that sounds so scary oh
well natural next question yes is you
take you to the dark side of the moon
from the cheeks to the front that is too
I'm sure right like no comments
I don't know has anyone yeah I'm sure
somebody has had their tattoos
and it may or may not have been in the
shape of a dragon
yeah I regretted it instantly yeah
and people are getting it pierced people
are getting a tattooed just oh yeah oh
for sure for sure yeah somebody's out
there I don't Jordan Allen doesn't have
any yeah I've none that is that is one
thing that I swore to my dear Mother I
would never do I'd never get a tattoo I
thought about getting a sleeve though at
one point I'll either do a sleeve or
nothing
okay yeah I've been I've had that same
thought I've had so many nightmares
about tattoos it's absolutely insane
nightmares where I go through the
process of I get the tattoo and then I
get it lasered off in the within the
same dream oh and then I wake up check
myself and I'm like what do you think
that means what does that mean yeah
that's interesting I think I've always
went back and forth on if I wanted a
tattoo and then I have the dream and I'm
like I guess I don't
oh okay it's quite literal then huh I
guess very literal I try to be very
practical yeah I dig it yeah okay I
don't know are you sure you're not
having commitment issues oh
well yeah that's exactly what it is with
tattoos that is a commitment but it
doesn't mean you know what I mean does
it mean like in other aspects of my life
yeah no I like committing to things that
I I can get you can get rid of a lot of
things like a house even a boyfriend or
a husband you can get rid of all of them
it's true it's a good point it's like a
lot of work and like legality sometimes
getting rid of a tattoo is arguably more
work it hurts is how it's painful it
takes a long time it's multiple sessions
you just say I'm done I mean Griffin do
you have that because you said you don't
want to just put anything on your body
it has to mean something for me that was
always the biggest limitation is I don't
I'm trying to think of something that
would be valuable or mean so much to me
for the entire duration of my life
and that's the hard part is here's my
advice for that
um this is only only my personal
perspective but uh the reason why I went
so long without getting any tattoos was
for that same reason and then at some
point I realized that my values and the
things that are important to me change
over the course of my life and nothing
like very few things will actually
remain that meaningful to me yeah and so
it's more important to me to just get
things that like my first tattoo was
just something that
it was a wizard and I've just always
like dug Wizards and I was like I'm
probably not gonna hate Wizards in 10
years and so like most of my tattoos
like the the snake wrapped around the
knife on my chest is like not super
meaningful I just thought it would look
badass and it does so yeah yeah and some
of them have some meaning to them but
like
um yeah I've I found like not getting
too precious with them
is just as important as not being like
too flippant
it's kind of a tap it's a tapestry you
know it tells a story over time that's
at least that's at least how I Justified
my worst tattoo what's your worst one oh
well it's it's not that it's like a bad
idea it's just I got I got a G clef and
a bass clef on my arm and just the it
was my first one and the guy who did it
you know I just went to one of those
unresearched just walked in was like Hey
I want a tattoo you know it's like the
Fantastic Sams of tattoos yeah
and and I was like well you know what at
least whenever I look at it it'll be a
reminder of that time in my life yeah
and that's that's what it was for me
um so I decided to get better ones after
that
after having made that mistake but only
up yeah yeah only up from there because
you have a beautiful full sleeve thank
you yeah that was done by a guy named
Josh Palmer he's up in uh Lodi Stockton
area
um he's yeah he's great I actually met
him in Minnesota when I was living there
but then uh we were both there for like
exigent circumstances and then we ended
up both back in California so I would go
up there and see him back in my
motorcycle days I would take my bike up
there it was a nice ride
but yeah I had the bug for a while I
think it's all out of my system now with
the exception of maybe a chord or
perspective logo so that seems worth
doing yeah for me it is yeah for me it
is I think it's just been such a part of
my life that it makes sense
I uh when I was in high school like how
you guys talk about changing I went
through a time where I was super into
Jesus like very religious so I was
Christian and then I right after that I
became atheist oh and so I became like
spiritual after that and so I've always
been in the spiritual Lane but when I
was like 16 and into Jesus I like kept
begging my mom to get this Bible quote
and like she said no and I was like in
tears I was like you hate me typical
teenage stuff yeah that's the worst mom
ever I hate you and then a year later
like I didn't even claim the man so
could you imagine if I had that tattooed
on my body yeah and it's like well no
wonder that that's what parents are
there for they're like bro you have so
much growing up and learning to do you
still want to get that quote then you
can get it when you're 18 19 whatever is
that the the cutoff is that 18 is that
when you're allowed to well go make a
decision on your own right yeah oh yeah
without consent without parental consent
yeah unless you go to a really unless
you go to a like a sleaze ball or like
shady shop which if if you find a tattoo
artist who's willing to tattoo you
underage you probably don't want to get
tattooed in that shop anyway that's very
valid yeah yeah it's not really
something to mess around with to be
honest
well it's it's interesting because
because Jake you got the full sleeve all
at once
right or did you was it in pieces the
first one not in one session necessarily
but the first one I got I was only like
and then I got one like a year after
that and then I didn't get one for a
couple of years and then I got a proverb
and then and then I got the sleeve uh
but you you got like the sleeve done at
once it's one cohesive design no
actually I got the eagle and then uh and
then I got the Lions and then I got the
sword with the crest on it so you were
like kind of spotty with it and then
kept filling it in rather than like
gradually coming down well when I when I
met Josh we started talking about doing
a full sleeve and so the idea kind of
arose over the course of a few years and
it was like the first thing I wanted to
do was get uh I wanted to get an eagle
because in my family crest there's a
Griffin and a griffin as you might know
Griffin is made up of an eagle and a
lion
and it's two of those things combined so
then I had the Griffin up I have the
Griffin up here and he wraps around my
shoulder and then I said okay well let's
let's do an eagle let's end Griffin's
down or an eagle and lions down here and
that was kind of the plan
um but it it happened kind of in pieces
those are kind of some of my favorite
tattoos personally because my roommate
he is also building it piece by piece
and I kind of love it because every
single one of them on his arm is a
different story yeah you know and
something that that you can like inquire
about so such a good conversation
starter which is why I'm kind of bummed
that I I may never have them you know
just due to that do that promise and
like I don't know it they just seem like
they're they're so cool and I wish I
could also dial back like how intensely
I'd take them yeah but yeah it's a it's
an interesting one though like when
you're raised to not
have the mic as an option it's weird to
like even play with the idea of them
yeah yeah yeah no it's different for
everybody for sure and you know you are
demarking your body and you know that's
according to a lot of religious
Traditions that's not exactly what
you're supposed to do but then according
to other religious Traditions that's
what you're supposed to do right so
they're you know if your body's a temple
they're the stained glass windows
brother yeah it could be yeah you know
what I mean a little bit of art say that
about the like Cadillac tattoo on your
thigh I don't know about that one
Griffin you're kind of going for that
like Patchwork of ideas look I've
noticed yeah that's uh that's definitely
like my my favorite style of like
coverage is just like wall to wall
almost like uh like an art gallery like
you're just covered in individual pieces
yeah I like that a lot yeah
crazy so anyway Jordan not Coleman
Jordan Allen sorry yeah she just goes by
JC now and and that's basically a
majority it's kind of settled I just I
want that to be known I don't know
Jordan Coleman if you're okay with this
but we've kind of settled on JC you have
it objected so yeah it sounds cool too
like everyone's into it and then like
I'll just take Jordan and then you can
take that I I don't know man everybody's
into it
but your you go as Jalen yeah
look at her while saying Jordan but are
talking to me
and that's my favorite
that's my favorite moment is it
I can feel I can cut the tension with a
knife all right let's move on
Jalen yes you you got married and you
went on a honeymoon dude I did I got
marriages yeah before you actually talk
about it I have a question
it we've been wondering if your wife is
in fact a real person if she's real yeah
yeah it's I'm gonna meet her this
weekend so
like it's all been building to this I'm
only down about 200 Grand I keep sending
her money over zal and then you know her
flight's coming in this weekend maybe
yeah
Jake Jalen already lost his reading Wing
once my reading win
wedding ring ready wig
this morning so you're like three days
in no all that matters is I got it on
now okay and I've actually gotten used
to it very quickly but yeah it's crazy
it's crazy being a married man sorry
boys I'm off the market
guns off the market I'm done so I you
know it's a quick story about that I
lost my wedding ring um oh and uh it was
it was my dad's wedding ring oh no it's
just the ultimate
Burn yeah in the studio I took it off uh
it was like a Friday I was about to go
home uh took it off washed my hands set
it on the sink in the in the in the poop
dungeon yeah and uh and I left the
weekend and there was a production of a
couple friends that that came in and
they had some extra people there that we
didn't know
and someone took it and if somebody must
have taken it because I left everywhere
I went down the drain no it I went I
looked everywhere like down the drain
under the little Cabinetry in there like
behind the toilet in all the cracks like
everywhere that sucks man who would take
a ring that's so lame
I don't know but yeah somebody must have
because it was just gone and since the
since then I haven't worn one because I
was like that was it that was the one is
yours tattooed no I've seen people get
the initials tattooed on their finger
and or just the actual band They
tattooed too now oh really yeah they
just tattooed I I like the the rubber
ones I've always you know we've been
talking about doing that for a little
while and I know they tear a lot but I'm
just worried wearing this around no yeah
more for like all you gotta do is is if
is if you are in a conversation and
you're not wearing one and somebody like
starts talking to you you know in that
way as if like they're interested in you
you just that's a daily occurrence for
me
[Laughter]
is unprecedented
just immediately you just immediately
shift the conversation at least this is
what I do I just immediately shift the
conversation to my wife and children
that's the move 100 then it's like you
know yeah and then a lot of times
they're like oh married must be a nice
guy that's the thing and how true is
that I hear it all the time that people
are actually more attracted to married
because you know what it is it's a mark
of value yeah it's like oh this this guy
must be a keeper yeah I'm gonna try and
take it
I know I rock this I rock this non-stop
in Vegas for the bachelor party weekend
not not for mine but for a friend of
mine yeah and I just I didn't take it
off I like it I really like it and I
like how it looks too it makes me feel
more adult than I feel a lot of the time
well because that's not I know I know so
it's a really justification with your
wedding ring and like horse blinders on
just walking around screaming I love my
wife
I have the photo up I'm like she's come
she's flying in this weekend
the hamburger board wrapped over your
shoulder of like your wife's picture
do not talk to me I am happy leave me
alone
oh man but yeah it's it's you know
obviously like you know leading up to
the wedding itself like I never planned
anything in my life I I'm the guy who
will like show up to the thing and have
a good time but man I have so much
respect for people who plan anything so
planning a wedding is like the first
cold turkey move was way harder than I
thought it was gonna be and we did a
backyard wedding thing so we thought
keeping it small and like that that
would help a lot but then you got to
worry about things like what kind of
Cutlery do you want I don't even know
there's more than one type dude I knew
about the fork and the spoon and the
knife but
[Music]
what is a shrimp stick and why is it
nine dollars per shrimp stick to rent
and then they find out it's wedding and
they bump the heck out of the price of
everything man when Wendy and I were
looking at it so we're we got married
under kind of interesting circumstances
like we had been dating for
what was that like uh four years and
when I by the time I asked her and
um we're in Minnesota helping take care
of my dad because he was like he was
sick and he and he passed away at the
end of it and it was kind of sad and we
looked at the cost and we were like okay
we have 15
000 maybe to spend on this and that
included the ring oh wow because I
hadn't bought the ring yet yeah
um and so we we were just like man like
the last thing we want to do after doing
nine months of this like life Excursion
is then plan another thing and spend
like money we don't have on on this
thing and so we just got married in our
backyard and my brothers uh and my and
my sister came up with their families
and we just did like a nice thing in
Orange County
um like Newport Beach
and that was it and I'm glad we did I
mean my aunt was kind of mad she was
like this would be the perfect thing to
like get the family together but I I
just I couldn't do it yeah when you go
get married I know and that's the thing
like you you do have to put your foot
down with like you know what the family
wants too and it's such like a trade-off
of yeah what do you want versus what do
they want and honestly going in I was I
will equate it to this I I had uh A5
wagu at a place called Alexander
Steakhouse in Pasadena I did it for for
Adrian Adrian just my wife at the time
we were three years in and she'd always
wanted to try it it was two it was a I
think it was a hundred and eighty
dollars or something for three ounces
something I'm sorry I don't remember it
was absurd but they're one of like 30.
bro dude they're one of like 30 odd
places in either California or the US I
don't remember that is certified to
serve this grade of A5 wagu from Japan
or something they have a big plaque on
the wall might be BS but I believe it
and we went in there and I was like
there's no way this is gonna be worth it
but we'll Fork out the money for the
experience and then just call it a day
and it came out and we spent I'm not
even lying we spent over an hour eating
three ounces of steak because we were
just in absolute ecstasy I burned
through all my serotonin and I was
physically exhausted by the end I was
like I can't believe it but it was
actually worth it and that's how I felt
about the actual wedding itself not the
act of getting married but the moment
and like the family being there and like
looking up and seeing my my parents and
you know like those kind of precious
moments you you kind of think oh it'll
be a blur and it's so expensive and then
all of that melted away in the moment
and I was just a total crybaby and it's
like it's weird to have a clear-cut best
day of your life but it's like so easily
that that yeah I know it's it's really
cool man so I'm buzzing we're just we're
we're goofy right now man we just moved
into our new place and we're
we're literally sitting eating take take
out on a on a twin mattress which is our
makeshift couch and we're just we're
loving every second of it man it's like
the best it's definitely I get the the
idea of like the honeymoon phase right
it's like everything's just exciting and
we're digging it man so I love the fact
that you guys
waited and then like lived together
after the fact you don't see that yeah
very often anymore it's interesting it's
like in the next chapter like I I kind
of live my life in chapter phases yeah
and I like that personally and I try to
soak up as much of the current chapter
as possible like all the aspects of it
so for me the idea of roommates and like
just having your boys and going home I
had three roommates so I just go home in
the four of us would just watch sports
and hang out and go out and and now that
that chapter's closed it's like this is
the new exciting one so we're like
discovering all these things about each
other in this new phase and man I'm I
could go on about it forever just why
don't talk about it because then I just
turned Goofy and everyone gets awkward
I love it dude did you really go to Bora
Bora for your husband dude I look from
the beginning I said if we're spending
anything on the wedding I wanna I wanna
drop buckets on the honeymoon I care
more about the honeymoon than I do about
the wedding and I have from the
beginning because the honeymoon is like
you only get that once dude like that's
the special time it's just you too yeah
it's you two you like get to just goof
out together and like be together 24 7
for this period and experience anything
you want and I asked her I was like what
like what are you what is your dream
honeymoon and she's like oh I've always
just I don't know if it's doable but I
always wanted the over water bungalows
and I was like no joke that is my exact
dream honeymoon so I was like we have to
do it and so you know I'm like we do
this once this is the only real reason
where I can feel good dropping Stupid
Money uh there's no other real reason
why I could like quantify it in my life
and so I was like let's just do the best
and just taste it taste that life for
just a moment and then just know how how
good it can be and so we went Bora Bora
over water Bungalow at the same Regis
and it was like so far into the middle
of the Pacific Ocean it's crazy it's a
speck I'm looking at it on a map right
now it is it's so cool it's a spec I
don't know how they found it I see it on
Instagram
it's like halfway between Australia and
California yeah yeah it's like in
between Australia and Mexico it's kind
of nuts so it's pretty far distance it
is it was a like an eight hour Mexico
and Australia it's really as clear as
what like Tick Tock makes sense Jordan
I'm not joking look here's anyone on
those walkways the best way I can
describe it is this
if you die and you go to heaven this is
the waiting room for heaven nice it's
it's it's untouched it's like yes there
are there are westerners there and there
are like a couple Resorts there but the
same region is the biggest one and
there's like 90 like Villas or whatever
and that's the biggest one so in total
you're looking at like maybe a thousand
westerners are there but the rest of it
is just like this insane untouched Gem
and looking at the sunset silhouetting
the mountains in Bora Bora it felt like
a 2d animation like at any point like it
was a miniature or something stop motion
and if like you could see Hands reaching
over the mountains and like picking
things up because it was too perfect and
then this this uh Stars would come out
and there's no moon there right now like
they have uh you know 53 days in a row
or whatever where there's no moon in the
sky and what that means is your eyes
exposed for the stars and you get to see
so much more of like the sky uh and you
get to see like the dust of the Milky
Way and you can even see a black hole so
it's like what it feels like a different
world uh and it felt like we shouldn't
be there so we got pampered up the Wazoo
it was absurd it was like the greatest
five days I hope you have pictures
because oh yeah she because I left my
fudge really sick before we left no
extreme like the sickest I've ever been
and I was like hot and like kind of
passing out but we couldn't change the
flights they're so expensive we couldn't
we couldn't change anything so I'm like
in the waiting room at LAX just on my
deathbed lying on the floor outside the
cage slowly dying and we get called onto
our flight and I'm in such like a zombie
state that I just get up and walk into
the plane and only when I'm there and
seated in my seat I go to get my phone
and it's not in any of my pockets and
then I realized good Lord I put it next
to me in the gate and once you're in the
plane they don't let you off you're done
so I bet I'm begging the the French
speaking because we went Air France or
whatever so the french-speaking
stewardess and she didn't understand
what I was talking about but she
basically let me know I can't go off and
at the last second before we go and I'm
just you know when I get back off to do
a new phone I have to rebuild all of it
it's chaos and I got a call on my uh my
Apple watch and it was
um one of the Air France employees who
had found it and said we're gonna put it
in storage and they did thank God I
think it's because it shattered on the
back yeah
still the vent one and I think that's
why they didn't take it no one took it
because it looks like it's just you
can't sell that it's genius it's the
perfect camouflage so yeah anywho maybe
I'll never fix it you know they should
make cracked phone cases that just looks
like they're crazy so no one will ever
take it's genius so yeah so Adrian has
all the photos of the trip and man it
was it was Bonkers so now we know how
good it can be so it's like uh it's like
an old volcano
it is yeah like the whole thing and I
guess the island sinks over time and
that looks like it looks like it's
sinking because yeah it's like a bear
it's like a barrier reef where it has
the ring Reef or the ring Island around
it and then there's the Mountaintop in
the middle and it's surrounded by water
yeah and it sinks and it creates those
uh matus I think they're called
something like that where it's like the
flat land and eventually that whole
Mountain will be gone wow and it'll just
be the Flatland so I need to get there
you need to get it's gonna be gone in
three months dude
[Laughter]
meter a year or something but oh it is
it is kind of crazy so you have a couple
you only have a couple million years
left yeah you better book it now because
flight prices just go up the closer look
now guys yeah
helmet like it's so much more worth it
to pay for that for you guys have that
experience because at the end of the day
for weddings you're just paying for
everyone else to have an experience at
your wedding yeah so it's like if you
pay 50 or 5 000 if everyone's there and
they love you they're gonna enjoy it
yeah but a five dollar honeymoon
compared to it this is however much that
was yeah this is this was very much like
the treat of hey we plan the the only
thing and the biggest thing that we've
ever planned let's treat ourselves and
like unwind and reset and you were there
for like a whole week yeah yeah it was
like five nights six days it was amazing
amazing but I'm glad to be bad guys
because I don't know I always get that
creative itch whenever I go on vacation
I was just like I want to make something
so when we got back I was just so revved
and ready to go and I came in with some
hot energy on Tuesday and I needed to
dial that that that that back a little
bit but yeah I'm just ready to create
now that we're doing the Animorphs thing
I'm scared dude this is like the perfect
I'm so happy they photo scanned me
yesterday I don't even want to know yeah
it's it's a weird one Griffin has this
tendency to walk by our desks at the
worst possible time it's it's insane how
consistent the plans it he plans it yeah
you must plan it y'all are just doing
some like really cursed stuff uh all the
time yeah because it's like every time
it is every time and it's yeah I'm
starting to question myself I think at a
certain point I can't keep saying well
his timing is just perfect
um but yeah it's that idea I'm very
excited about I mean can I yeah am I
cool to go into it a little bit yeah
yeah we're taking the animals out of
Animorphs so
it's so dumb and like we were all
sitting you know brainstorming an idea
and uh Ren is actually reading Animorphs
right now and so he happened to be he
happened to be reading animals yeah and
you know the covers everybody knows the
covers of the transformation to the to
the animal and how cursed those are like
the in-between photo of like the bug boy
who's completely in pain
um starfish girls starfish girl yes
a classic
otter boy like yeah there's there's so
many good ones and you know we all grew
up with them like in the either the
library or the book fair or whatever so
we all knew about him and it's like what
can we do with this because we've always
wanted to do something with Animorphs
and yeah it finally it came to fruition
and we put our heads together and
eventually came up with the idea we have
of taking the animals out of them and
having the transition be just from me to
the animal form but the animal part
never appears it's just my body being
crushed into the the shape of you know
an otter or whatever the animal is and
it just being just a skin tomb
essentially of this Beast that wants to
die
everyone's favorite part of the
Animorphs is the in between and so we
take it to the very end and because you
can still see the person yeah so now we
just strip away all the animal and take
you to the very end and how do you guys
choosing what animal goes with which
person it's you have to you have to feel
it yeah what does it mean spirit animal
what is your spirit animal JC yeah sea
turtle a sea turtle it's my favorite
animal oh I love the way they live man I
love the ocean just like the vastness
you can kind of get lost in it okay and
it's peaceful and they live long simple
lives they're like hey I need to lay
some eggs crawl up to the sand all right
guys I hope you find your way then go
back and they just chill dang you know
it's like this isn't there not really
stressing and they don't really have
like many many predators either like see
actual sea turtles yeah not once they're
full grown yeah so do you do you relate
to them because you feel like you're
similar to them or why they're your
spirit animal I think because I love the
ocean and I love being deep into the
ocean like I like feeling lost and like
I don't I like when it gets so cold that
your feet can't touch and you kind of
you're like oh Mother Nature has more
terrify you do yeah maybe that comes
from like me living in Florida and like
hurricanes and we go out really deep and
just I love the idea of Mother Nature
taking its course rather than like us as
humans think that we can have all of
this control and like really nothing is
in our control at the end of the day
that's what I feel about water
yeah that's how you should feel about
water I think yeah but if you're just
like paddling at the shore like there's
nothing compared to like
just diving like in the middle like I'll
be out in the Pacific Ocean like see
dolphins I'll just dive in with them oh
that's cool yeah I
I don't know I love it
and you have a big portable shell you
take and you're telling us about you
yeah
protection act like I'm a sea turtle
hang out with them it's actually some
weird thing that you're not telling us
about teacher
what about you cheers
uh the animal I relate to the most you
know um
I don't know I don't really like a want
to give you that ammunition
right there man you can just thought
about what spirit animal you are
or what animal you just like
animal I'm in my favorite animal for
like my entire life has been sharks I've
always found sharks to be really cool
and really fascinating
um
there's all the many different varieties
and um
how how ridiculously fine-tuned they are
to do like one specific thing which is
eat one specific kind of animal and an
alarming rate yeah and uh survive for
millions of years yeah not want a shark
they don't live for millions of years
but like they've been around like
aren't they like one of the the oldest
20 million years or so whoa yeah well
there's the Megalodon too right like you
you know the mega oh yeah Megalodon is
uh
dude can you imagine that's almost been
a terrifying place oh yeah dude
yeah there's a Megalodon skull I think
in New York at the Natural History
Museum
and it's Bonkers well it's probably just
the Jaws because uh sharks uh except for
their jaws and their teeth do not
actually have solid bones they have
cartilage skeletons yeah it's probably
just the job there's a job there's a job
like at the San Antonio aquarium there's
a jaw
replica of the size oh maybe that's what
it is then and you can stand in it
almost
yeah
[Music]
what yeah I think it's more like lions
lions it's those are
oh
[Laughter]
are you thinking of lines I don't know
what you're talking about why is he
thinking of a lion what do you mean an
aquatic Aquatic Life is such a such a
fascinating thing though like but when I
was a little kid I I wanted to be like
my dream job was like marine biologist
like I wanted to like study sea life
because it's it's crazy like you like
learning about like sperm whales and how
they like did you know that if you're in
the water near a sperm whale and it
decides to like Ping you with its sonar
full force
um it could kill you because of how loud
it is what yeah they and they will do it
at a lower volume because they know
you're alive like they're very very very
very very smart and like when they're
just checking you out to see what you
are they'll kind of pulse their sonar
through you to like look at your insides
and apparently you can start to feel
your body heating up
from the like the amount of kinetic
energy that is like a microwave wow it's
bananas there's whales are like
like sperm whales um
some marine biologists theorized that
like they're they're they're clicking
and their calls is like potentially a
language that is like more complex than
human speech and we just like
haven't figured it out because it's not
you know
relatable to any kind of linguistics
that like humans have and
yeah
Wales marine marine life it is it is a
crazy crazy world Beluga well they said
they're like the canaries of the sea
because they talk so much it's just like
constant I don't want to do whale noises
right now but yeah I used to I used to
have a stuffed beluga whale actually
that I would like sleep with every night
I'm like kind of like you I really like
aquatic animals I think we're diving in
and figuring out what your uh what your
spirit is yeah
sperm whale
something in the scene it's a mighty and
beautiful creature it truly is yeah
there's because Craig if I'm wrong maybe
you know this sharks they can sense your
like the electricity in your body they
can smell the fear they yes because they
can sense your fear because my dad and I
uh as a birthday gift for him we took a
trip to South Africa quite a few years
ago and in Cape Town there's tons of
great whites and we went shark diving in
the little cave cages that's a bucket
list item for me yeah and they threw a
foam seal on the surface they hadn't had
any sightings in a few days so we
weren't really holding our breath there
but they threw a foam seal just in the
shape of one and I wasn't scared of the
ocean going into this trip and watching
the just the black water just a mouth
emerge out of the nothingness yeah and
bite it clean in half and then disappear
all fast I had a whole new appreciation
for how terrifying especially when they
told me hey when you get in there
they're gonna know you're there and
they're gonna know you're scared and if
they know you're scared they know your
prey and if they know your prey a they
may just want to take a bite out of
curiosity and they don't like humans so
they probably won't finish the meal but
then you're down a leg and I'm like yes
that's awful yeah so not only do you
have to be in the water you have to be
just gonna mutilate you yeah
I am I I imagine that there is there is
like you see pictures of great whites
and you're like oh yeah that's big but I
imagine seeing one in person like
there's no way to prepare yourself
they're like 20 feet longer than this
yeah that's so crazy I think let me look
that up like yeah I think 26 because
this one was a younger one so it's 13
feet and that alone was humongous so I
can't imagine females females can get up
to 16 feet oh it's up to 16. wait really
oh how big can males get okay the
longest one always the largest white
shark reliably measured was 21 feet 21
okay 21. so yeah 13 I guess is you know
it's still big but it felt it felt
humongous and how about fights and whale
carcasses from Southern Australia
suggests that some are as long as 25
feet oh thanks so crazy the guy who was
on the boat had been working there for
one season and he says during whatever
the seal season is where the seals are
moving through he says he saw five get
caught in a day on the on the water
where they're like jumping out and
trying to get away and sharks are just
coming out of nowhere just munching them
20 feet 20 feet is the height from the
floor of our studio to the low part of
the bow the bow get out of the boat
trust yeah forget that dude forget that
why does that exist because the ocean is
vast it's huge like they can be that big
because there's plenty of room and
there's not a bunch of people building
cities under there yet
we're coming for you yeah we're coming
for you great whites and like being
suspended in uh in a in a liquid you
know allows for like larger bodies
yeah yeah gravity doesn't have as much
of an effect on like they don't have
like sharks don't have knees yeah they
don't have to have knees they hold them
up elephants got knees I don't know if
you knew that but I didn't that's
actually really interesting well I made
a joke literally today that manatees
have no bones and they're just bags of
meat
and so like obviously I was joking well
thank you so much obviously I was joking
and to hear now in the same day that
sharks don't have bones and they're just
bags of meat and cartilage you've
shooketh me to my core dude they're
they're so let's see if manatees have
Bones hold on manatees have bones I've
been looking at Manatee bones almost all
day like the sharks sharks are so like
they're like the opposite of manatees
man
mammals
manatees are made they wobble up on land
they need them bones
waddle up on land they are made so
mammals yeah that's that makes sense
because even their their little fins are
actually just hands they got fingers
they can't use zones in there yeah
there's hand there's finger bones in
there
um I I did Google sea turtle because we
had asked about how old a shark is 110
million years oh God I was way off
yeah and they said that they were there
turtles or sharks sea turtles turtles
110 okay for for me the ocean like the
deeper you get the more I love it like
when you start getting to the level of
where they're translucent and emitting
their own sources of light the angler
fish
oh my God
in my dreams for years just the freaking
ghouls at the bottom that's why James
Cameron just got his submarine and was
like I'm the hell I saw ghouls in person
that's so sick have you guys ever seen
the algae that occurs like once a year
it's like this like it's like the
bioluminescence when everything when
like boats go through any type yeah the
waves crash and it just is neon blue oh
it's so cool it's beautiful
yeah it's so cool down there all right
Jordan Jordan Allen what say you about
your about your uh
about your spirit animal oh about my
spirit animal yeah
I'm kind of curious for you to assign me
one real quick I have one in my mind but
I'm curious I'm curious what what the
outside world would think uh you might
not like mine but the first thing that
comes to mind is a prairie dog
prairie dog white Prairie because you
know like they're they're always happy
and they're always like oh that's sweet
isn't it they're always like friendly
and wanting to play and like
good-natured I feel like I get that vibe
from you wow those are like really
really good dogs yeah Daniel gave me
golden retriever which I thought was no
no not a dog a prairie dog a prairie dog
yeah I don't know the difference but I'm
putting it on you like specifically a
prairie dog no not dog
oh it's a rodent you know that's a rat
Jake that's not that's not a dog
that's a dog oh no that's a lie prairie
dog
it's a rat it's a herbivorous burrowing
ground squirrel native to the grasslands
of North America is it my teeth is that
why it's giving meerkat it's giving
Beaver meerkat meerkat that's another
name for it oh man okay yeah meerkat
okay where did they put dog in the name
that's a weird weird because I was
thinking of like Lassie yeah
are meerkats the same as uh
I feel like meerkats are not your energy
because if memory serves me right
meerkats are uh incredibly homicidal
creatures apparently they they
apparently they kill each other in in
huge numbers they're very aggressive is
that truly
if memory serves me right I have pretty
bad memory but I I feel like there's a
lot Griffin is it all the podcasts you
listen to that gives you this random
information this yes random batch of
trivia I love it yeah if
20 of meerkat deaths are murders where's
our mothers killing The Offspring highly
social form packs of two to Thirty ew
look out look how evil look at that
picture that is kind of like I see it
now
the number one most murderous mammal
well that's definitely not what I meant
that's the best twist I could have ever
hoped for
eign
I only have one animal at a time
are you sure are you sure that meerkats
are this aggressive towards one they're
murderous man I just said it we just
Googled it
it said what's the number one aggressive
mammal okay hippos were honestly 37
percent of the knifings in the Serengeti
Americans the other 70 Army
did you know that 37 of the knifings in
sub-Saharan Africa are meerkats
did you lock the back door honey no why
yeah
oh no other encounters between members
of different packs are highly aggressive
leading to severe injuries and often
deaths 19 percent of meerkats die by
conspus cons specific violence
I assume that means not species on
species crime oh wow
let me hold on we're doing this guys
like there's no like Rhyme or Reason to
why they're killing belonging to the
same species okay yeah
so there you go that's definitely not
what I meant Jordan I meant like your
Carefree friendly nature and you're oh
my gosh generally a amicable attitude
not the knifings because those are just
alleged at this stage so maybe we just
go with the golden retriever
nobody proved anything I've always
resonated with the naked chimp
that's not a species chips are pretty
violent violent too though they are man
I have seen you throw your [__] before
well why were you in there
are you in there I thought I locked that
door yeah that was that time that he
like we we found him and then he got
really embarrassed said he was like
method acting but we asked him for what
and he like we had to wash them off I
was in character yeah for the thing
which character
yeah all right so you're you're
self-ascribed spirit animal is a
chimpanzee naked chimp well
no well some are more naked than others
Jake what I want you to Google naked
chimp because chimpanzee boy oh boy look
if you guys is this an actual species
yes yes they're the second most
murderous animal
I don't think I don't think naked
chimpanzee is a subspecies I think it's
just a chimpanzee that's lost all its
hair no no no it's a chimp that plays by
its own rules and shows what it wants to
show uh hairless mutation
um yeah uh I'm hairless this is from the
National Institute of Health a hairless
mutation introduced into the chimpanzee
human last common ancestor six million
years ago diverged hairless human and
hairy chimpanzee lineages
uh that doesn't
mean
that
oh God this is a real thing oh yeah
welcome
so why do you welcome to the Brotherhood
so you're you're a spirit Brotherhood
your guide into the spirit realm is the
missing link
yes yes yes
I think we all need to go watch Brother
Bear and come back tomorrow what is that
shout out Aaron Blaze oh wait you
haven't seen brother no I watch a
surprising movies
oh this is an old one yeah rather big I
don't know when it came out
Jake is just so this is fascinating I'm
like what I did the same thing man it's
okay it takes a while to like adjust
the whole world view should be reframing
my world view really 2003
dude they're out there
just imagine the background of corridor
like Crew videos they're just like a
chimpanzee and a diaper and someone's
like running airplane
it's probably me oh my God
yeah yeah yeah
there's a beauty in how they just bear
all you know what I mean they're just
they are who they are they hide nothing
they show the world and the world judges
them for it the world
so ugly man I love them I don't know
they're just my favorite animal I love
them dude they're weird look at this
thing man that looks like when you go
over to Grandpa's house too early it's
like oh I didn't know you were here yet
that is a very ball sack that's the sack
of sacks man
oh man Grandpa Tell me about the war
crap we talked about they look like us I
told you friends were coming over we
share like 97 of the same DNA yeah so
now that you see a hairless and you're
really like that's us that's us dude
that's me
we are just naked chimps just yeah we
just split six million years ago that's
about it yeah yeah just a little bit
better posture man they got the people
they got to keep the the hand feet and
we got the gene that like we invented
Coca-Cola right I feel like they got the
better end of the deal dude yeah they're
they're so strong though like actually
Christian can you pull up that picture
one more time yeah these things are like
stacked like they're looking at their
muscles you'd kind of think that they're
like kind of strong right but their
their muscles are like so much stronger
than our muscles it's like this I have
muscles yeah they just rip your arms off
Jim's scared Jim's actually scare me
more than any other animal look at that
dude look at that dude but you know
their one weakness they do have one
severe weakness and they share it with
gorillas and also orangutans they cannot
float in water because they're months
muscle and bone density is too high they
sink in water gorillas chimpanzees and I
believe orangutans are alive oh wow
horribly afraid of water because they
will just drop like a rock it makes
sense man it's like corded steel dude
those freaking biceps and what's crazy
is like obviously they're they're hyper
intelligent monkeys are and they know
when they attack you they know they know
the parts to attack and that's the
scariest part about them they know the
soft spots and they're they're like they
go for the balls both the eyeballs and
the other ones and they go for the
fingers they just look to maim you when
they're mad and it's the most Terror now
this has nothing to do with why I
associate with them I just want to
clarify that I'm still trying to figure
out why you associate they're honestly
to be totally transparent they're just
my favorite they're my favorite so I I
want to try and be more like them I
don't think I don't think yeah I go home
and I just strip completely
strip completely naked natural for
someone to maim
foreign
why are you so violent what is this
violence that you have it's you know
good I think I think I smile too much
and people don't trust that so are we
gonna do an animorph of you just
morphing into a naked gym
Matt and Dean picked mine I don't know
they picked but they they assigned me my
my spirit animal we assigned everybody
their spirit animal you know based on
just we we had some conversations down
here and I'm sure and worked through
some stuff let me let me hear it let me
in on the insides who would you
I mean the video's not gonna be out yet
so it's kind of a surprise so I don't
know that I want to spoil all right
everybody remember and you're listening
to this before the video's out you're
you have to stop here this is a warning
this is a warning there will be a
spoiler here I'll give you one I'll give
you one tasty one okay
um Matt he doesn't know this yet
he really wanted to be an otter I'm not
sure why I can kind of see it though no
he's talked about he loves otters he
loves him he wants to be an otter and uh
that's a whole thing with him it's
giving it's yeah it's giving it's giving
honor but the problem is he asked to be
an otter and you that's a No-No that's a
No-No in the animals world yeah yeah uh
and so being from Florida right I don't
even remember why we talked about on
camera and at the in the moment it felt
like a perfect fit but we've made him a
manatee
Oh I thought you're gonna take a
crocodile no we made him a manatee and
it's hilarious because watching the body
morph because they they all start in
like their normal standard position so
he's kind of just like he's he's begging
in his uh animation not to be changed
and then he just gets like lifted off
the ground and his legs shrink and
flatten and his head grows big and
oblong and he just assumes the form of
this busted Manatee and it's so freaking
funny it's gonna be great how are you
hiding that from him uh with the monitor
situation being as close to his
he's working from home today because
we're back to back in the studio yeah so
he will just naturally glance over
shoulder do the same thing and it would
have ruined the whole thing so either I
was gonna work down here in the podcast
room where and shut the curtains yeah or
take advantage of today and we finished
it today and so
that's done but for the other people who
are going to see I'm gonna need to be
sneaky that's gonna be the hardest part
yeah sneaking around and making the
Transformations but it's the it's the
craziest video it's I just keep I keep
catching Daniel smiling and laughing
watching it because it's so chaotic and
I don't know how he's gonna do it but
Daniel is a master editor so he'll find
a way to tell the story he'll find a way
he'll find a way if anyone can it's
Daniel yeah oh man it's beautiful
what have we done I woke up this morning
with a big fat smile on my face knowing
I'd spend the day doing this so all
right
last topic here um
Jalen
when you were away
we did a trick shots video and it's
coming it's coming out this weekend I
heard about this in passing and I don't
know exactly what you did but my first
thought was how the heck did you do it
without me like how could you how could
you betray the 1-1 you know what I mean
so this is a this is officially a
the side quest to beat uh uh to get a
side item so that I can beat you which
is my main boss you have a side item uh
yeah I have a side what do you have I
can't tell you until do you know what
you have or are you I know what I have I
know what he has what is it gonna work
it I think it's gonna work great I think
he I think you're in for trouble that's
what I have to say about it do you know
what this is uh my my headphones cut out
for the last uh 45 seconds so he says
item to beat me in
uh Dude Perfect
uh screwdrivers trick shot render
challenge
are you aware of it oh you're talking
about the uh
like the yeah what is that what is that
the thing oh yeah I know about this yeah
I love that you did this I don't really
understand it but I know so if you're
interested in catching up on the Saga
you can watch the the previous two where
Jordan and I compete against each other
and uh this when by the time this
podcast comes out there'll be another
one coming out
weekend and uh yeah I had to face off
against Sam
I can't wait to see that he brought
training you is he yes is he Judas
Brotherhood he he was honestly trying to
beat me but the lesson was to to break
me so that he could rebuild me
um so it's like you're this is your
Rocky Montage basically yes this is
totally my Rocky Mountain so imagine the
Rocky movie if at the end of the Montage
he's still lost because that's what
you're gonna be watching
he lost yeah but the same way that
Lightning McQueen loses in the first car
spoilers
well yeah okay it's like from 2006 or
something so it's actually still a
victory so no matter what you're going
to lose Jordan I just want you to know I
am fascinated to watch this
um I might need to level up myself we'll
have to think about how I can how I can
Elevate because the Wally future dude
it's it's right within my grasp and I've
been enjoying the victory there's been
some comments about the wind too I must
warn you oh have there oh do people well
here's the thing about CG baby I'm
allowed to do whatever I want
I'm the god in that CG world I can
control the wins if I want to you can
take nothing you can do about it I can
take the lid off the cup if you want to
I can take it off
first or keep it up or put it back on
baby it's my world and you're merely
living in it let me tell you well you're
not because you're not in it anyway it
doesn't matter direct threat point is
the meerkat's coming out point is people
can hate on the window they want the
wind exists in the real world and
therefore can exist in my system the
difference is I can control it and
haters gonna hate the Winner's gonna win
baby
I'm very excited I've enjoyed this song
there you go you see where he's at
people you see my enemy before me yeah
you must be defeated we can't the wildly
future baby I'm fighting for it unionize
I just like saying that so much oh man
all right sorry
ah all right well I'm very excited about
this Animorphs video it'll be out the
weekend after this episode comes out uh
and uh man after that a whole bunch of
goodies in the bag we got that punch for
punch episode coming out soon we got
Anime rock paper scissors 2 On Deck so
stay tuned everybody because it's gonna
be a wild summer
wow plays out baby you all ready
[Music]
murders
podcast this week's podcast was
sponsored by uh
the wild world of the undersea laugh
thanks for watching everybody see you on
the next one